au dessus sur les droits des femmes la
motion à l'avortement en pas d'accord on
fait des quolibets lottotech on rigole
voilà
non
n'est ce pas manquer d'elle j'écris vous
avez qse je n'ai pas là je peux vous
garantir que moi j'ai des amis qui sont
agriculteurs et ils sont là dedans je
peux je les invite à venir en affaires
mais elle va ça et va se rendre compte
que c'est pas exactement qui s'exprimait
avec ac d'affirmations elle nous
reprocher de qualité vous quittez vous
quittez vous quel côté papapapa la pampa
je connais pas de poulet qui tangue à
léonie des pigeons non plus qui par leur
avait fait quoi vous avez pas kaka telle
vous avez vibré la seule qui caquettent
est et un à droite vous savez que jose
sont à ma gauche va papa parle parle
parle parle parle parle de vous dans le
bourg au total non j'étais toute cette
bla bla bla j'étais plein temps pendant
sa durée longue à s'échanger leur ca
durer très très longtemps